thank you madam chair
well dear colleagues thank you indeed
for this very very important debate as I
said we will not stop supporting Greece
in addressing these challenges we are
committed to continuing working
hand-in-hand with the Greek authorities
and together with our agencies on the
ground to mobilize all support needed we
know what situation and most of you were
very vocal of that but I was also very
clear during my introductory remarks
excuse me commissioner
colleagues would you please be so kind
and either take your seats or continue
your discussions outside we can hardly
hear the commissioner
especially the colleagues in the back
and in the aisle hello are you listening
hello hello would you please discuss
outside and please be quiet and take
your seats thank you so I repeat what I
said before that we need a common and
sustainable solution I would like also
to thank you for your support in this
regard this but also the previous
Parliament has worked very hard I'm sure
that with your continued help the new
common European Asylum system can become
a reality soon dear colleagues friends
today is one of the last occasions for
me to speak to directly and openly in
the context of a plenary meeting before
my term finishes let me therefore first
of all thank you wholeheartedly for the
personal and collective exchanges that
we have had as well as the excellent
cooperation over the past five years it
has been an honor and a privilege
working together with you in order
to work for our citizens and respond to
unprecedented challenges for our common
house Europe to deliver a Europe that is
more resilient more secure but also more
humane to uphold the values and
principles upon European Union is built
this has been a constant battle and it
will be a continuous challenge for the
years to come because as I said before
migration came to stay for many many
years and Europe has to be better
prepared and this is what we have been
doing together in the last five years
how to address certain fears and
concerns of our citizens without
becoming isolated intolerant or
exclusive earlier this week we all
commemorated 30 years since the fall of
the Berlin Wall a division that was
larger than Europe but then ran through
its very hard the fall of the Berlin
Wall shows the power of our citizens and
the power of our stamina of not giving
up of believing both individually but
more importantly as a community no
single person could have demolished that
world but a collective spirit did this
spirit should guide us in an
unpredictable future the European Union
our Charter of Fundamental Rights which
celebrates also 10 years by the way our
second area of free movement all of this
is about keeping that collective spirit
alive about excuse me again
this is this is really I can hardly
understand what the Commission is saying
I don't know about you but if you would
please I mean the people who are
concerned are not even listening now
would you please stop talking in this
volume because we can't really hear the
Commission speak so it's I think a
matter of respects to take a seat please
thank you well the past five years have
shown that whatever comes our way
migration climate change terrorism can
only succeed if we work together in
unity and trust dear colleagues
migration and security challenges are
testing our vision our resilience our
commitment to our European principles in
this house is a fundament in this
endeavor this is what I experienced
during the last five years I am proud to
have shared this supreme duty we told
all democratic political forces in this
house I came here five years ago as a
pro-european Greek politician and I'm
going back as an even more convinced and
a committed active politician of Europe
but above everything as I convinced the
European citizen thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much I think especially
though your last words were worth
listening and now we turn to the council
madam Minister top Iranian please madam
chair honorable members of the
Parliament let me thank you for this
valuable and timely discussion winter is
indeed coming there's no doubt about the
need to immediately address the many
shortcomings we observe in the hot spots
in an efficient way as I have mentioned
I have no doubt that the new Greek
government is intent on improving
conditions and amending the loopholes of
the system that resulted in people
waiting for too far islands linglong
please I mean this is ridiculous
silence please DME piece there are real
people also miners waiting living in
inadequate facilities we are discussing
about that now and yesterday dear
Pease we had in this very plenary a
vivid discussion on the rights of
children and many of you referred to the
rights of migrant children the United
Nations Convention on the Rights of the
Child is the most widely ratified human
rights treaty in our history all EU
member states are party to it thus there
any peace it is our common
responsibility ours as EU citizens ours
as EU institutions but also ours as EU
Member States to show solidarity to
children in migration high number of
minors in the Greek hotspots remains a
matter of deep concern all my de minors
no matter how old no matter their age
all minors they need a vision of a
better future the most positive vision
of the future the EU is able to provide
the winter is coming
as we Finns certainly know what it means
as mister Osmani for instance rightly
pointed out without delay there is a
need for a proper accommodation
available to all parentheses and microns
and that should not be too difficult
this is a minimum and a starting point
for a further help and concrete
assistance and I can only urge the Greek
authorities and the Commission to speed
up all the important work they do so
that the people most affected can see an
improvement in a difficult situation
they are living the army piece
unfortunately so far there hasn't been
sufficient will among the Member States
to proceed according the Commission
proposal yet there is a clear need for a
duckling reform and more comprehensive
approach to manage migration Finnish
presidency is pleased that the future
Commission is aiming high here the
support that we are all looking forward
to
new legislative proposals by the summer
at latest we need take action now
thank you very much madam chair for this
very timely discussion in a minister
ashley said I met Josh Parker and Viacom
dangling coats at student abdomen
dentistry